my dad was for Thanksgiving my dad said
uh buddy two bears thing is that like a
it's like a big deal I said no it's just
our podcast and he was like yeah but my
friends have said the there's a Kool-Aid
clip and I went oh yeah like I drank I
drink Kool-Aid and he goes huh I said
well I don't know and we're at my
sister's house I could just play the
club I'd never seen it and my dad was
crying laughing and he and he goes you
drink a gallon of Kool-Aid you drink a
gallon of Kool-Aid and I was like I was
like and again I'm going I didn't
realize how up and I watched it
the first time yeah and I was crying I
was like seeing someone else's life it
really was a weird guy drinking a gallon
of Kool-Aid yeah a grown man a grown man
but bird
here you are today yeah drinking a
gallon of Kool-Aid I I it's I can't stop
oh